this video is brought to you by legal
eagles copyright course calm giving all
creators the tools they need to fight
bogus copyright claims YouTube stands up
for creators everywhere and fights back
against an alleged copyright troll who
not only apparently tried to extort
fellow youtubers but tried to have one
killed yep it may be true this case is
wild hey legal eagles it's time to think
like all of the lawyers that YouTube
just hired to go after a copyright troll
who may have been trying to extort a
bunch of individual creators YouTube has
filed a federal lawsuit against a
YouTube creator who they claimed was
trying to extort fellow creators and
actually may have swatted one of them
now before I begin I want to emphasize
that these are only allegations all of
these facts come from the complaint that
YouTube filed in federal court a
complaint is the document that you use
to start a lawsuit and it contains your
side of the story
YouTube is the plaintiff here that means
they started the lawsuit and because
we're still in the very early stages of
this particular lawsuit all of the facts
are gonna come from YouTube so take
everything with a grain of salt now
first let me give you some background to
help understand this lawsuit that
YouTube is filed Congress passed the
DMCA in 1998 to deal with copyright
infringing material online it allows
websites to not be responsible for
copyright infringing material that its
users upload under certain circumstances
the DMCA is one of two laws that give
websites a safe harbor the other being
the Communications Decency Act section
230 which is something I will definitely
cover in the future because it is in the
news every single day these days the
bottom line is that under the DMCA a
website isn't liable for copyright
infringing material so long as they take
down the offending material when they
receive a notice from the person that
owns the copyright this is called a DMCA
takedown notice you'll find it in 17 USC
512 which is a totally easy law to
understand you can look it up by
searching google for 17 USC 512 now
youtube asserts in its complaint that
one Christopher Brady issued a false
DMCA takedown notice to extort certain
youtubers people that made minecraft
video
basically the complaint alleges that he
claimed he owned the copyright to
minecraft and therefore demanded that
youtubers pay him money or he would
issue a DMCA takedown a third one now
YouTube has a system where if you
receive three DMCA takedown notices your
channel is deleted when a DMCA takedown
notice is levied against your channel
YouTube gives you a strike and three
strikes and you're out of the YouTube
game now allegedly Brady would issue two
DMCA takedown notices and then try to
extort hundreds of dollars from those
creators by threatening a third takedown
notice which would result in potentially
the deletion of these peoples channel
now if true this is illegal and violates
the DMCA section 512 this happens I've
talked to creators who have dealt with
false DMCA takedowns I myself have been
the victim of a false DMCA claim so this
is definitely something that exists in
the world but it's also relatively
unusual the big boys the music labels
and the movie studios rarely mess around
with DMCA claims now sure they abuse the
Content ID system that YouTube has
created but a DMCA takedown notice is a
little bit different it's created by
copyright law and YouTube doesn't have a
whole lot of control over it basically
from the people that I've talked to
behind the scenes none of the big
players will file a DMCA takedown
without talking to a lawyer first or
often they'll have the lawyer issue the
DMCA takedown why is that because it's a
big deal as paragraph 8 of YouTube's
complaint states to submit a takedown
notice using the forum parties must
affirmatively check a box next to a
statement that reads I acknowledge that
under Section 512 F of the DMCA takedown
any person who knowingly material
misrepresents that material or activity
is infringing may be subject to
liability for damages if you issue a
false takedown not only are you liable
for damages and in other words the loss
of revenue that comes from the videos
but you're also liable for attorneys
fees and when you're talking about
YouTube that's a lot of fees now I know
YouTube gets a lot of flack for taking
down videos pursuant to the DMC
takedown requests but YouTube actually
doesn't really have much choice in the
matter
that's apart from the whole Content ID
system which YouTube controls paragraph
9 of YouTube's complaint says the
YouTube receives thousands of DMCA
takedown requests each week through his
online web forum and also received
notices by email postal mail and
facsimile I guess that if anything this
is probably an understatement
I guess that YouTube probably deals with
on the order of millions of DMCA
takedowns per year and YouTube doesn't
really have much choice in how to deal
with these particular claims it's all
enshrined in copyright law both the time
frames and the the consequences so if
YouTube gets a DMCA takedown they don't
really have much choice but to take the
video off of YouTube otherwise YouTube
would potentially lose their copyright
safe harbor and become liable for
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of copyright infringement actions per
year so let's talk about the actual
facts of this case in paragraph 21 of
the complaint YouTube alleges that in
January 2019 defendant Brady using
several falsified identities send you to
multiple notices of alleged copyright
infringement pursuant to the DMCA claim
the two videos uploaded by Kenzo and two
videos uploaded by Abby raids supposedly
infringed copyrights that he owned in
the next paragraph YouTube asserts he
represented that he was the original
creator of those videos and that he held
the copyright to them the complaint goes
on to assert that Brady tried to extort
a third youtuber and in fighting one of
those allegedly false DMCA takedown
notices that youtuber provided his true
home address as required by law that
makes sense that is one of the statutory
requirements to being able to fight a
DMCA takedown notice the problem as
alleged in this complaint is that part
of the DMCA allows you to issue a
subpoena to get that information when
it's uploaded the purpose of which is
that if you are issuing a DMCA takedown
you need to be able to take these people
to court if they file a counter notice
and put the video back up the complaint
goes on to assert that on July 10th
the third youtuber announced via Twitter
that he'd been the victim of a swatting
scheme that day and they go on to define
swatting as the act of making a bogus
call to emergency services in an attempt
to bring about the dispatch of a large
number of armed police
officers to a particular address if
that's true that this guy did use the
information he gained by abusing the
DMCA takedown process to issue a false
SWAT call against a fellow youtuber in
the hope that the SWAT team would be
called to this guy's actual house that's
a felony and this guy should be in jail
this is a despicable act if true people
have died because of swatting 'z because
if you're playing a video game that
involves gunfire and the SWAT team hears
the gunfire from the outside they might
come in with guns drawn and people have
died in the course of being falsely
swatted the bottom line is that YouTube
alleges that this particular individual
Brady falsified DMCA takedowns committed
perjury and used that information that
he gained to extort fellow youtubers and
may have even tried to kill one of those
youtubers frankly I was astounded when I
saw this lawsuit being filed by
YouTube's 17 USC 512 eff does in fact
give service providers like YouTube a
private right of action to sue over
false DMCA takedown notices I've just
never seen a service provider actually
file a suit like this if true this seems
like a very very good thing on behalf of
most youtubers and a blow against
potential people who are trying to abuse
the copyright process for their own ends
when they don't own the copyright to
allegedly infringing material this could
be the first of many lawsuits on behalf
of YouTube protecting its youtubers and
if indeed the allegations in the
complaint are true I think YouTube is
doing all of us a favor by getting rid
of some of these YouTube copyright
trolls I think YouTube is trying to send
a message against this troll and
potentially others they have the
resources to do it and I will repeat
that we don't know all of the facts this
is all one-sided so please do not Doc's
the defendant Brady or attack him in any
way online let this legal process play
out YouTube in its prayer for relief is
asking for compensatory damages
attorneys fees and an injunction in
other words a court order that forces
the defendant to stop this is probably
bad enough I checked and this case is
being litigated
a local firm in Omaha where the
defendant lives and also by a very
well-known attorney with one of the
top-tier law firms Wilson susini which
is the law firm that has handled Google
and YouTube's most important and famous
cases and I was curious how much
Wilson's tasini charges and according to
court documents if you can get a 10%
discount for a lead partner at Wilson
susini you will only pay $900 an hour in
other words if this defendant loses
he'll probably pay on the order of
$1,000 per hour for hundreds of hours of
attorney time also parenthetically that
Phil DeFranco covered this lawsuit
earlier today and although he did
generally a great job covering it he put
some special attention to the end of the
complaint specifically the prayer which
asks for such other further and
different relief as the court deems
proper under the circumstances kind of a
question mark saying they pray for such
other further and different relief as
the court deems proper under the
circumstances and so something even
potentially bigger here he kind of
freaked out about this that's a totally
normal thing to put in a complaint it's
just a catch-all a lawyers cya to allow
them to ask for something else not
specifically mentioned in the complaint
so Phillip my dude reach out to me next
time I'll let you know what is notable
or not in a complaint like this as an
attorney I have dealt with copyright
trolls for a very very long time and I
am tired of creators getting pushed
around by bogus copyright claims so I
decided to do something about it I made
copyright course calm to give all
creators the tools that they need to
fight meritless claims and stand up for
their rights online it's not only an
entire Law School course on copyright
distilled into a few hours but it's also
a system that I developed to fight
claims on YouTube and other platforms I
should know because I get a lot of
claims against my videos even though
they are clearly fair use and spoiler
alert made by an actual copyright
attorney and trial lawyer copyright
course com is all the tips and
strategies that I use to beat claims and
make sure my videos are safe I think
it's time that we fought back against
the copyright trolls and made fair use
actually fair you can check it out at
copyright course comm right now and you
can get early access to the beta course
which will be half the price of the
final course you'll get every module as
soon as
comes out and your comments will help
shape the final product I am really
looking forward to being able to help
creators and fight back against the
copyright trolls because there are a lot
of them out there so do you agree leave
your objections in the comments and
check out this playlist that has all of
my other real law reviews over here
where we deal with all of the pressing
legal issues of the day so click on this
playlist and as always I will see you in
court